there's been a lot of buzz about dubious
chemicals in the environment that might
contribute to some pretty frightening
stuff like obesity breast cancer thyroid
issues and they seemed to lurk
everywhere in pesticides cosmetics and
especially plastic packaging in light of
this it's understandable to start
panicking
but before you do let's hear what
molecular biologist Bruce Bloomberg has
to say on the subject he's been studying
the link between synthetic chemicals and
obesity for around 15 years so he might
be able to give us a better idea of
what's really going on and what to do
about it
bad news is Bloomberg confirmed that yep
we're surrounded by these chemicals one
of the most well known is BPA or
bisphenol A which shows up in water
bottles cans milk cartons and more you
get from thermal paper receipts like I
have I have these receipts from a recent
trip all of these things are coated with
bisphenol A and it goes right into your
skin
BPA has been making headlines for years
about whether or not it's harming us and
while FDA funded and independent studies
have conflicting conclusions the bigger
heart of the issue is this BPA is hard
to get away from because it's a key
building block in the tough clear
flexible plastic called polycarbonate
and that proximity to food is what
concerned scientists like Bloomberg you
don't want to store food in plastics
because some fraction of those plastics
will leach into your food the BPA
molecules that make up plastic are bound
together by what's called an ester bond
which is extremely sensitive to heat so
when you heat up your food in plastic
that heat breaks some of the bonds
releasing the chemicals into your food a
survey by the CDC of 2517 people
estimated that over 90 percent
of Americans have detectable levels of
BPA in their urine and BPA isn't alone
valleys which make plastic flexible can
also leach into food when heated and
reviews of hundreds of studies have
linked BPA and phthalates to heart
disease obesity and type 2 diabetes not
to mention a 2015 review linked
phthalates with impaired neurological
development in children which in 2018
prompted the American Academy of
Pediatrics to announce that families
should avoid plastic food containers
entirely and other Studies on animals
like mice and monkeys have shown that
these chemicals can lead to problems in
the lungs brains and reproductive organs
this is about the time someone like me
would probably panic but there are ways
you can avoid these chemicals Bloomberg
suggests it's best to just stick to
heating your food in anything but
plastic now quick aside bpa-free plastic
containers aren't the answer because
research suggests that bps and BPF the
most common replacements for BPA might
have similar effects on your body
instead opt for replacements like
ceramic or glass containers you have to
do the best you can and it makes sense
to me
to do the things that give you the most
return for the least effort and here's
the best part once you reduce exposure
those chemicals slowly leave your body
as bloomberg says they're stored in fat
cells which eventually die and
ultimately leave your system don't
stress about it
right do your best and make conscious
choices to improve things
you